so you learned about this
when you went to hear julian bond speak
but was your first reaction what mine
was when i saw this which is
really nobody's done this before
no because i know doing historical films
that usually no you know i don't choose
a topic that had been done before but as
pat said 12 years ago this summer i went
to hear him and
rabbi david saperstein who's right now
are an ambassador for religion in the
state department and the topic was
blacks and jews and i thought i was
hearing a talk about the civil rights
era
and sure enough julian bond as you can
see in the film his father his uncle had
been
funded by rosenwald and he knew very
much the legacy coming up from the south
so i i was just like at the edge of my
seat and
a light bulb went off just like in my
previous films that this had to be my
fourth film and it's also the third film
about the american jewish experience but
really about all us you know american
history
he was a philanthropist of a different
mold from what we see nowadays you think
of andrew carnegie and his libraries and
those have endured and the rosenwald
schools some being restored and
certainly the legacy is still here
what made him so different if you
compare it to philanthropists nowadays
well several things i think one is the
fact that he grew up quite humbly
and i think also very much influenced by
living across the street from lincoln as
a matter of fact when i went to make my
trek to springfield i called the park
service and i said you know i know
you're oversea
um the lincoln house and my
understanding is julius rosenwald grew
up across the street and they said well
we don't know where that is so i come
i'm having a meeting in the park service
meeting and all of a sudden the
park ranger says to me you know by the
way we realize the building we are we
use every day is actually the old julius
rosenwald house wow so that's all about
history you know it's a over a hundred
years ago so i think he had this
feeling from lincoln a sense of history
but i still say so much of it was what
he learned from his rabbi emile hirsch
this rabbi who taught very much about
repairing the world who himself had been
from luxembourg had gone to the
university of pennsylvania this will all
be on the dvd had played football
and when he came to run that
congregation that reformed synagogue it
was on sundays things were different
than a lot of german jews when they came
to america reform judaism was practiced
less religiously for lack of a better
word but also people worked on saturday
and people have altered my denominations
would hear them and the greatest rabbi
hirsch story is
apparently that something really bad had
happened at one of um the meatpacking
industries and he called the guy out on
it he picked up took his wife and walked
out of synagogue i would have loved to
have been there that day and my line is
i don't see that kind of religious
leadership today except for maybe the
new pope
how
how difficult was he's got fans yeah um
how difficult was the detective work did
did you start at the rosenwald schools
and then work forward or did you start
in the present day and work backwards
well i'm very lucky i always decide to
do a film and it just happens a book has
been written with
partisans of filner there had been a
book written about the vilna ghetto and
woods with hank greenberg ira berkow had
edited a book that hank had just
finished
with molly goldberg there was a young
scholar in the south who just written a
book on her on her and with this
film the grandson peter askaly who you
see a lot in the film stephanie deutsch
had just written a book and mary
i got to learn how to pronounce her last
name hoffsteller
had just written a book and then of
course
i think isabelle wilkerson's book on the
great migration taught me a lot about
what that movement was so it's a
surprise yeah you go to those books
and then you know the family had
archives
um but that's you know after 36 years in
the business i
you become a detective and you you look
at more footage and more footage and i
have to say with this film i'm using
more feature film than i ever did before
which
i hope it worked for people here but i
know recently i showed the film to
someone who's actually a very respected
journalist and he goes i go out to lunch
with him and he says to me you know
aviva i can't believe you found the
footage of julius rosenwald's parents
getting married
oh you mean the the gene wilder moment
yes
and i thought oh well yes it's very
interesting how i got that um
and of course who else could get clint
eastwood and in color too
who else could get clint eastwood
speaking yiddish
and by the way if anyone knows clint i'm
still waiting for the final permission
this is also part of this week there's
also some footage that
um you know securing footage
including the footage we saw today i was
i'm not going to mention which footage
or which studio but i was calling and
calling for months finally i got on the
phone with someone who said well why do
you want your footage and why do you
want a good price so i'm saying i've
worked on this for 12 years uh you know
i'm a struggling independent filmmaker
we sort of have most favorite nations
because actually hbo and cbs came
through with you know the interview with
gordon parks and
dr quinn and oh and rawhide free and i
said you know it's really important and
she says i don't know and i started
crying now i didn't expect to cry i
didn't script to cry but as my nieces
will tell you i'm an easy cry and i
haven't gotten a lot of sleep the last
four months so she softened a little and
i said and yes i'm going to have the
screening at the museum of tolerance
which i did last monday she said ah
i took my daughter there she cried there
so i said oh you have a daughter how old
is she oh she's going for a driver's
test tomorrow and i said oh good luck
and before i knew it i got a hundred uh
dollars a second instead of a thousand a
second so well done you um sometimes but
tears do work you know there is crying
in getting rights maybe not in baseball
but in getting right
and it's also better to get forgiveness
and permission perhaps right oh no i
mean you have to do that
well you you used a lot of feature films
in there i think i recognize a clip from
the spencer tracy movie fury am i right
the mob scene no but why use the feature
film stuff so this is interesting um i
feel and are there any screen i can't
see you all out there but i assume
there's some screenwriters they're the
wonderful people out there okay well i
think you all because i know i've also
written us uh several scripts is i think
you do as much research as we do as our
uh as documentary filmmakers and i think
a lot of scripts really are based there
there's actually one film that was on
the great migration and i loved it but
they couldn't they didn't have a digital
ties we couldn't get copies of it it
would have been more footage of people
coming up african-americans coming out
so
i always go to feature footage i had
with hank greenberg i used gregory peck
not being able to check in the hotel and
gentlemen's agreement
so i decided look i've got to go for it
and then i'm thinking peddlers
i love dr
dr quinn medicine woman and sure enough
hassia diner the scholar says
and
the peddlers would go door to door and
then they would sell to immigrants to
african-americans and native americans
and there it was exactly in that order
in the film and i thought you know
that's a bingo moment now in terms of
besides bragging rights having sidney
podier in the film who of course
you know was very famous at this
institution
i um
raisin in the sun was written by
lorraine hansberry who died way too
young but she grew up in chicago and
that film is really about chicago and
segregation and her her father was a big
designation lawyer so i knew it fit
about how crowded conditions were but it
also fit in terms of the back story of
lorraine so i was a way of honoring her
as you went to people to interview them
about the schools and the fund
were they grateful were they
all over themselves to to be eager to
talk to you about this perhaps no one
had approached them on this before some
were very shy but yes they were very
grateful i have to admit there are three
people i did not interview gordon parks
that's from the hbo and we'll give him
credit maya angelou was from an earlier
um
interview she had given some years ago
and luckily um i used the backdrop of my
house my mother's an abstract
expressionist painter so luckily her the
back of her
her house looked the same but the day
she said
the programs are like the lynching and i
knew that julius rose had it was great
and then aussie davis you know i
respected him a lot as an actor and i
think it really
gave the the marian anderson story an
extra point but i didn't interview him
also but of course we got permission to
use the footage